atentamente
[Música]
hace más de un siglo que existen los
bares restaurantes y sus ancestros los
restaurantes económicos parisinos en
este establecimiento de la localidad 10
de parís nada ha cambiado o casi desde
su apertura en 1906
el restaurante económico julian es a la
vez un restaurante una cafetería y una
invitación para devolverse en el tiempo
soy una aficionada del arte nuevo y ese
tipo de ambiente un poco vintage retro
entonces para mí era un lugar ideal para
cenar
es un viaje en el tiempo totalmente
imagina las bellas de la época que
desfilaban aquí no sabemos si tenían la
misma carta que nosotros en un siglo de
existencia este restaurante no ha
cambiado la receta que lo ha hecho
exitoso
proponer a los clientes algo bonito
bueno y barato un desafío cotidiano que
requiere una organización concorde
haga un rosetón no sabe hacer un rosetón
mire es como los zapatos
si quiere hacerlo como profesional debe
esconder el proceso de abajo así no se
ve es más estético si jefe de acuerdo
buenos señores buen servicio
abajo en la cocina todo es casero los
huevos mayonesa los filetes
platos siglos preparados bajo la
supervisión de christoph whatsapp
las bandejas igor por favor antiguo chef
estresado
es una cocina familiar yo diría
tradicional una cocina muy simple
productos frescos se trabaja de manera
sencilla una salchicha puré es una
salchicha que elegir que tiene gusto
grasa canónigos un puré casero su boda y
cepillo como en casa
la diferencia con la casa es que aquí
cada porción es calibrada al gramo
aquí pensamos en todo la guarnición la
cargo antes del servicio para preparar
los platos para que puedan salir
rápidamente hacemos nuestra facturación
con base en el volumen
los bares restaurantes son reconocidos
por sus platos pero también por la
calidad del servicio
sandro psn y el arte del servicio es más
que un argumento comercial es un arte de
vida incluso el director recibe en
persona a los clientes
al sol afuera donde prefieres vamos te
lleva
pendiente de todo siempre le habla a
todo el mundo ya lo atendieron su misión
acoger a los clientes con clase pero con
discreción
nos encontramos aquí llevamos dos pero
terminamos siendo diez es un poco el
lugar donde nos encontramos nos da
alegría ver a la gente pero no por las
celebridades no en sandro psn guía y la
referencia de las celebridades una
verdadera atracción para los habitantes
y los turistas que a veces se pueden
transformar en un motín entonces para
proteger a sus clientes privilegiados el
jefe no duda en ayudarlos a escapar
discretamente
pasamos por aquí para evitar las
agresiones afuera
volteamos a la izquierda y hay una
puerta disimulada nos vamos por aquí las
celebridades toman este camino
tuvimos que ayudar a salir a karl
lagerfield también a rambo stallone
había casi un motín
la responsable de este entusiasmo
brigitte bardot
en 1956 está filmando en el puerto de
sandro para la película y dios creó a la
mujer
hizo de este restaurante su cafetería y
desde entonces las celebridades no han
parado de desfilar allí desde los
gendarme de san tropez hasta hoy en días
celebridades y curiosos aprueban al
unísono este establecimiento
a la celebridad la ubico donde le gusta
y hago lo mismo con el cliente frecuente
del barrio que viene todos los días a la
gente le gusta ser reconocida e
instalada donde le gusta que se le llame
por su apellido y sentirse importante
con el paso del tiempo los bares
restaurantes supieron seducir a sus
chefs renombrados como paul bocuse
el guión el maestro abrió uno en esta
antigua estación
voy a instalar estas personas los haré
esperar cinco minutos les preparó la
mesa está bien
kevin cn bien el responsable de la sala
se enamoró de este lugar
estoy un elemento me gusta con el
movimiento llega práctica cuando tenía
16 años y luche todos los días por este
ambiente aquí se puede servir hasta las
6 de la mañana ha de ser necesario pero
bueno paramos a las 11 de la noche
buenas noches
[Música]
en la cocina también hay efervescencia
un toque gastronómico de los platos y en
el servicio
la cocina está completamente abierta
hacia la sala y william está en el
centro de la escena
y
gastronómico con clase popular en un
siglo de existencia los restaurantes no
han perdido una arruga y no pasan de
moda en la gastronomía francesa
[Música]